[Applaus]
werde zuschauer hier meldungen der heute
redaktion
kurze zeit nach bekanntgabe der
grenzöffnung durch die ddr hat in berlin
ein ansturm auf die grenzübergänge
eingesetzt viele hundert ost berliner
kamen ohne schwierigkeiten in den
westteil der stadt
sie hatten nur ihre personalausweise
vorzeigen müssen auch westberliner seite
wurden sie von jubelnden bürgern
empfangen
nach angaben von augenzeugen gelangten
rund 1500 westberliner unbehindert in
den ostteil der stadt am grenzübergang
bornholmer straße haben sich die
grenzposten ganz zurückgezogen
dutzende von west berlinern kletterten
auf die mauer und feierten ohne dass die
polizei einschritt und glücklich sein
will ich einfach nur glücklich sein
das ist endlich unsere stände die stände
der freiheit so wasserdicht ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nachrichten wie ein lauffeuer durch die
stadt bereits eine stunde nach der
ankündigung versammelten sich zahlreiche
westberliner an den grenzübergängen auf
ost-berliner seite nahmen am späten
abend von stunde zu stunde die zahl
derer zu die von der neuen
reisemöglichkeiten sofort gebrauch
machen wollten jetzt reaktion eines ddr
bürger überrascht die öffnung der
grenzen ab sofort veranlasste den
west-berliner senat zu einer eilig
einberufenen sondersitzung um auf den
besucherstrom eingerichtet zu sein
wurden letzte vorkehrungen getroffen
der regierende bürgermeister sprach von
einem historischen tag für berlin
ich bin sehr froh dass endlich
reisefreiheit für die bürgerinnen und
bürger der ddr gegeben worden ist
darauf haben wir wirklich 28 jahre lang
neben seit 1961 gewartet und ich denke
alle berlinerinnen und berliner und alle
deutschen sollten sehr froh darüber sein
dass dies nun möglich ist auch wenn
viele denken was uns das für lasten
aufbürdet das ist wohl wahr es ist nicht
einfach das zu bewältigen hier in berlin
bereits mehrere hundert ostberliner
nutzen in den späten nachtstunden die
neue reisefreiheit zu einem kurzbesuch
was alle kamen ohne gepäck die
abfertigung an den grenzübergängen so
augenzeugen verlief problemlos für den
heutigen vormittag wird mit einem
massenansturm in westberlin gerechnet
sed politbüromitglied schabowski hatte
am abend überraschend mitgeteilt dass ab
sofort die ddr bürger direkt über alle
grenzübergänge zwischen der ddr und der
bundesrepublik reisen dürfen
in ostberlin erklärt der schabowski vor
der presse diese entscheidung sei eine
übergangsregelung bis zur verabschiedung
des neuen reisegesetzes der bundestag
reagierte mit einer sondersitzung auf
die öffnung der innerdeutschen grenze
vertreter aller parteien erklärten dass
dadurch die mauer überflüssig geworden
sei gleichzeitig forderten sie jetzt
freie wahlen in der ddr den menschen in
der ddr müsse jetzt eine perspektive für
eine lebenswerte zukunft gegeben werden
sie riefen gleichzeitig die bundesbürger
zur solidarität mit den ddr bürgern und
den übersiedlern auf in warschau
kündigte bundeskanzler kohl an er wolle
nach seiner rückkehr aus polen
möglichst bald kontakt mit ddr-staats-
und parteichef krenz aufnehmen
er bot ihr ddr konkrete gespräche über
eine sofortige weitreichende
wirtschaftshilfe an
mit der öffnung der grenzen und der
ankündigung von freien wahlen seien
entscheidende reform ein entscheidender
form schritte getan worden erklärte kohl
gleichzeitig ermutigte er die ddr bürger
in ihrem land zu bleiben und sich dort
für veränderungen einzusetzen
kohl wollte vor journalisten nicht
ausschließen dass er seinen polen besuch
womöglich vorzeitig beendet unser ziel
ist nicht dass wirklich viele aus der
ddr wir gehen damit die infrastruktur
des landes die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung in einem hohen maße
natürlich entsprechend beeinträchtigen
unser ziel ist dass sie dort bleiben
unser ziel ist schon auch wenn jetzt die
grenze offen sind dass möglichst viele
rüberkommen sich mal umgucken und wenn
sie dann wieder nach hause gehen einen
zusätzlichen eindruck gewonnen habe aber
es ist eine gewaltige herausforderung
für die bundesrepublik werden äußerste
anstrengungen zu unternehmen haben was
in diesem fall auch jetzt bei uns sind
sich der infrastruktur geschehen kann
sein neues datum darüber muss man sich
im klaren sein
wir haben viele gespräche gehabt die
zahlen dimensionen die vorher schon wenn
man sie genannt hätten in der letzten
wochen als übertrieben gewollt nicht ich
habe immer eisern darauf beharrt dass
wir keine zahlen nennen im bereich
unsere vorbereitung
ich bin unmittelbar vor meiner abreise
heute noch weit über eine stunde mit den
verantwortlichen ministern mitarbeitern
zusammen gesessen wo man haben der jetzt
gefundenen zahlen entwicklung weitere
unterbringungen zu überlegen das sind
wir auf einem guten weg in dachau hat
der polnische ministerpräsident
mazowiecki aus anlass der polen reise
von bundeskanzler kohl ein essen gegeben
in den tisch reden wurden noch einmal
die unterschiedlichen auffassungen in
der frage der polnischen westgrenze
deutlich majewski erklärte polen geht es
um ein recht auf ein leben in
gesicherten grenzen bundeskanzler kohl
unterstrich dass er in der frage der
oder-neiße-grenze am bausparvertrag
festhalte wies aber gleichzeitig darauf
hin dass eine endgültige regelung einem
friedensvertrag vorbehalten bleibe beide
politiker bekräftigten ihren willen zu
einer engeren deutsch polen
zusammenarbeit schon eine stunde nach
seiner ankunft in warschau trafen sich
bundeskanzler kohl und der polnische
ministerpräsident mazowiecki zu einem
ersten ausführlichen gespräch im
vordergrund standen die gemeinsame
erklärung über das deutsch polnische
verhältnis gewonnen und die
zusammenarbeit für die nächsten jahre
noch vor dem start vor allem an einer
wirtschaftshilfe für polen interessiert
die bundesregierung will den polnischen
reformkurs mit einer neuen finanzhilfe
von 3 milliarden mark unterstützen
morgen trifft kohl den polnischen
staatspräsidenten jaruzelski die
wetteraussichten bis freitagabend durch
der donau und in bayern meist sonnig
sonst stark bewölkt und im nordwesten
etwas regen an der küste starker südwest
wind und höchsttemperaturen sechs bis
zwölf grad
voraussichtliches wetter in europa am
freitagmittag stockholm wolkig 7 grad
london bedeckt 14 paris wolkig 14
hamburg bedeckt acht berlin wollte ich
acht münchen wolkig sechs madrid weiter
20 rom wirklich 16 athen weiter 20 und
moskau weiter zwei grad
das waren nachrichten der heute
redaktion
[Musik]